we're streeting joint me now good
morning mr streeting good morning travis
um
you've become secretary of state you've
heard secretary of state and on their
response uh
he doesn't seem quite yet to have
decided that there are going to be more
restrictions um are they right to wait
and see what the data will show what
were two things firstly if there's one
thing that the sage report the minutes
published yesterday tells us if there's
one thing that our experience in the
pandemic tells us is that action sooner
rather than later
means that the
strength of the restrictions and the
impact on people's lives livelihoods and
liberties
is lowered so
action sooner rather than later would be
better
rather than worse
the second thing to say is listening to
sadja javid this morning
in that interview he looked like a
hostage to his own party and that's
because he is what we saw this week in
parliament with the huge rebellion of
over 100 conservative mps on what were
actually quite modest
measures
tells us that the prime minister has a
big problem when it comes to the crisis
of confidence in his leadership within
his own ranks
and crucially that is impacting on the
government's public health response so
sadja javid looks like a hostage the
good news here is that the labour party
is here to rescue him from that
situation he doesn't have to negotiate
with the people holding him to ransom on
his back benches because we will act in
the public interest we will put public
health before party politics and we will
work with
government scientists medical advisors
as we have done throughout the pandemic
to put public health first and that
should be the only focus of the
government well that that is immensely
generous of of you um but the truth is
you disagree with some of the detail but
basically you
support what johnson and javed uh want
well we'll be guided by the scientific
advice we're hoping to meet with the
chief medical officer and scientific
advisors today for a briefing on where
we are to test some of their assumptions
and to think about what might be
necessary there are areas where we think
the government can and should have gone
further already actually which is not
about restrictions statutory sick pay
should be higher because there are lots
of people who are supposed to be
isolating but feel they can't afford to
do so
as a result of the very sensible advice
that chris whittie gave the country
earlier this week lots of people have
voted with their feet have made
different choices about how to spend
their social interactions whether
they're going out socializing the
hospitality industry and others have
taken a hit through no fault of their
own and and support there is needed for
the industry the government could for
example with these covered uh loans that
people have taken out give people a bit
of a repayment break help get their
finances in order so there are things
the government can and should be doing
which they're not so it's not just the
case that we're voting to support
measures in the public interest we are
encouraging the government to go further
to help people are feeling pain in their
pockets yeah but with respect that's
that's all the nice stuff it's always
it's everybody's in favor of giving the
public more money will you be in favor
and will you be voting with the
government if they bring in further
restrictions for example
uh
a further lockdown well i don't think
anyone wants to see a lockdown i hope we
i hope we don't have to go but if the
data tells you that that's what's needed
as scientists are beginning to say this
morning will you be ready to vote for a
further lockdown but as i say trevor i i
don't think that a lockdown would be
necessary if the government takes action
sooner rather than later so we're you
know i'm not trying to be difficult
about this we're going to see the chief
medical officer and the scientific
advice when you say follow the advice
well when you say sooner rather than
later the scientists are saying today
today this morning get on with it
and i i don't quite understand what
you're saying are you what are you
waiting for to say let's get on with it
either you believe the scientist or you
don't well with respect the government
had this advice
on thursday in the in the form of the
sage minutes the government have access
to far more
information options advice than the
opposition do i don't think unreasonably
given that i saw the sage minutes last
night that i want to speak to the chief
medical officer and scientific advisors
so that we can come to an informed view
and i hope that will be today the
question is so we might ask you
something the question is well i think
we might hear something from labor
tomorrow the question is why is it
having received that advice on thursday
the prime minister has said nothing done
nothing well i can tell you why is
because he's hiding from his own back
benches instead of leading and that kind
of weakness in place of leadership
should really concern the public because
i think people out there know
that measures are necessary all they
want to know is what measures when and
how can i plan for them contrast across
that with and what's going on in wales
mark drakeford the first minister set
out a plan that takes wales right into
the new year i dare say people won't
necessarily like
measures who does but at least people
have some certainty they know he's doing
the right thing for the right reasons
and they can see what that path looks
like why don't we have a plan for
england you've told me you're meeting
the
chief medical officer we hope so we do
have a cabinet
so um
let's say 48 hours so we can expect
within 48 hours for labor to take a view
about whether we need further
restrictive measures or not i hope so if
the prime minister isn't prepared to
lead we've shown that we are prepared to
lead and we're prepared to do what is
necessary in the public interest we put
public health before party politics
early this week we will continue to do
so again i think it would be preferable
by the way for the government to have a
plan and for them to pick up the phone
and work with us in the national
interest we're prepared to do that too
but the question is how is it having
known this information on thursday
that the government have failed to say
anything do anything in fact the only
thing beyond the interview we heard from
the health secretary this morning his
other big intervention is an op-ed in
the daily telegraph today why because
he's talking to his party not talking to
the country he's negotiating with his
backbenchers he's not working in a
bipartisan way to take the action that
might be necessary to get the country
through this and that that's what i
think we should be concerned about the
prime minister's weakness is now
undermining public health well let me
ask you a question about something that
might be puzzling some viewers if you
think that the prime minister's
essentially the biggest obstacle here um
why are you voting consistently to
uh support his measures and essentially
keep him in office wouldn't be the best
thing for a responsible patriotic
opposition that thinks that boris
johnson is not fit to lead quote your
leader who is the wrong person to be uh
guiding us through this crisis wouldn't
be the most important thing number one
priority get rid of boris johnson if
there's a motion of no confidence
tomorrow we'd be voting for that we'd be
why because trevor you know as well as i
do had labour play party politics in the
way that you described with the votes
earlier this week the measures would
have fallen public health would have
been weakened and people would have
rightly said why is labour playing party
politics with public health you also
know if we take a table the most of no
confidence in the house of commons
tomorrow the conservative party mps
including those who think boris johnson
is a busted flush and an albatross
around the next they'd vote against the
motion because they'd pull together
so look there are lots of armchair
critics who say why don't labour do this
why don't labour do that the answer is
because we thought it through and we've
realized that these are futile measures
we're not going to play party politics
with public health and we are you know
what we are going to do is show the
leadership and responsible leadership
that the country would expect to see
from us
and that's what we've done this week do
you think if the government uh seeks uh
further restrictions do you think the
public is going to fall in line again
well i think
the press conference earlier this week
with chris whittie showed us that while
people have lost trust and confidence in
boris johnson they do trust as we do the
chief medical officer they do trust the
chief scientific advisor they do trust
the nhs so in the end i trust the
british people to do the right thing i
think what's reprehensible here is that
boris johnson through his own actions
and the actions of those people around
him have undermined trust and confidence
in public health messaging
from the government at a critical time
and that's why i think to be honest when
it comes to the next phase boris johnson
if he's determined to stick around like
a bad smell needs to take a step back
and push to the forefront of public
health messaging clinicians people on
the front line of the nhs because people
do trust them
and they do trust their experience and
so i think in the end the public will do
the right thing we're a law abiding
country but at the moment
people are making their own decisions
because the government isn't leading all
right there's a politics show let's
let's talk uh politics um
the uh and let's talk about the
by-election this week um to give him his
credit boris johnson took responsibility
for the tory's loss in north shropshire
when is um your leader going to take
responsibility for losing nearly
9 000
votes uh in this by-election last time
around you had more than 12 000 this
time you didn't break four thousand i
don't think we're disappointed by the
result in north shropshire well you lost
three quarters of your vote and you're
not disappointed i think it's a
significant defeat for boris johnson and
what north shropshire shows us trevor
steady steady you were second in this
seat the lib dems walked straight past
you come on
i think what north shropshire shows us
trevor is that political parties are
perfectly capable of making informed
judgments about where to spend their
resources and voters can be trusted to
make the decisions that give them the
outcome that they want in this case
removing a conservative mp and i get the
slightest bit disappointed by the result
in north shropshire okay you're
obviously having a laugh here but there
is a serious point here
doesn't this demonstrate that if you are
absolutely as serious as you purport to
be about boris johnson's failings that
the labour party the liberal democrats
the greens all now have to start
thinking if they really mean what they
say that it's time to start thinking
about an alliance that would actually
put you in power because that's the only
way to get rid of this person that you
never cease to say day in day out is not
fit to lead this country
i don't think that voters like the idea
of backroom deals and tax between
political parties i think voters are
perfectly capable of making their own
informed choices about the outcome that
they want to see
so you know looking at um the the lie of
the electoral map there will be some
parts of the country where uh getting
rid of a conservative mp the route to
that the best route to that the easiest
route to that is to vote liberal
democrat there are far more places in
the country where the route to getting
rid of a conservative mp and delivering
uh a labour government is by voting in
labor for voters voters can make more
borrowers
no i don't think that i don't think
that's a choice actually and and if
boris johnson leads the conservative
party into the next general election
more for the conservative party but
that's that's for them to worry about i
think what the labour party has shown
this week in particular but since
kiersten became leader is we've got a
serious leader with a serious team
capable of governing the country we know
we've got more work to do to win back
trust don't want to give your viewers
the impression we're in any way
complacent about this but we're
determined to do that work we're
determined to win the trust and
confidence of the people we can do that
without backroom deals and we'll put our
best foot forward and let the people
decide we're streeting thank you very
much indeed